on that point
if we discover life on europa
and you were brought in
you seem very excited but
how would you start looking at that life
in a way that's useful to you as a
scientist
but also not going to kill all of us
so like to me it's a little bit scary
because not not because it's malevolent
life like it's a
it's a dictator petting like a cat it's
evil
but just the way life is it seems to be
very good
at conquering other life so there's a
lot of science fiction movies based on
that principle
and that's sort of what causes the
public to be so scared but if you think
about sort of
would europa life be scared of humans
coming over and taking over
chances are no not even like earth
bacteria because earth bacteria would be
wiped out
in an instant in this foreign world
because they don't know how to
metabolize
energy that doesn't come from the types
of energy sources that are here
the levels of acidity may just kill us
all off and at the same way
in this in in the converse way if you
bring life from europa on earth
it'll die instantly because it's too hot
or because
it doesn't need to know how to cope with
i don't know the sun's radiation so
close to this
completely inhabitable zone by their
standards
so so what we call the habitable zone
might actually be the inhabitable
for them so the difference if the
environments are sufficiently different
you think we'll just not be able to even
attack each other and a basic
uh it'll take massive amounts of
engineering to create
machines that will go there and sample
the you know oceans basically drill
through
the layers of ice to basically sample
and see
what life is like there and detecting it
will probably be trivial it definitely
won't be dna based it's not like we're
going to send a sequencer
but it'll be you know some other kind of
combination of chemicals that will look
non-random
so if you had to bet if i took that life
form we find on
europa and like put it on a sandwich
that you're eating
and like eat that sandwich it'll taste
just fine
and you'll be well i know about that i
don't know
anyone will taste fine that's
interesting so the other question is do
we have
taste receptors for this where does our
taste come from
adaptations to chemical molecules that
we are used to seeing
so you think we don't have casebots for
things we don't even know about wow
so we won't yeah we want to be able to
know that this chemical tastes funny but
you think it won't be
it's likely not to be dangerous like it
it won't know
how to even interact do you think our
immune system will
will even detect that something weird is
probably
and it'll be very easy to detect because
it'll be very different from very weird
but it won't be able to sort of
attack i mean the scene from i don't
know independence day
where like they're communicating with
the other computer and they're like ooh
i'm in
i mean it's hilarious because like macs
and pcs have trouble communicating
[Laughter]
i mean let alone an alien technology or
even alien dna
you